يرتكب بعض الاشخاص مجموعه من العادات
الخاطئه التي تضر بصحه العين استنادا الى
عدد من الخرافات او ربما اتباعا لمقوله
اسال مجرب ولا تسال طبيب وبيتعاملوا معها
على انها حقائق مؤكده صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
نشرت تقرير عن ارشادات لعيون صحيه تتعلق
بعده معتقدات شائعه لدى الناس حول العين
رد عليها كبار الاطباء للتاكيدها هنا فيها
اولها ان
استحليت الموضوع
اولها مشاهدينا ان قراءه كتاب او النظر
الى جهاز الكتروني عن قرب يضران بعينيك هو
امر صحيح وقد يتسبب بمرور الوقت في قصر
النظر كمان يعادل القراءه في الظلام لا
تسبب تراجع البصر الا اذا كانت الاضاءه
خافته ما يؤدي الى اجهاد العين والصداع
وصعوبه التركيز
اما بالنسبه لقضاء المزيد من الوقت في
الخارج فهو ايضا مفيد للرؤيه اذ يقلل من
خطر الاصابه بقصر النظر بالنسبه للضوء فوق
البنفسجي فهو مضر بالبصر ويمكن ان يتسبب
في اضرار لا رجعه فيها لشبكيه العين عشان
هيك لازم نلبس النظارات الشمسيه ولكن
استراحه من ارتداء نظرات طبيه ممكن ان
يبطئ من تدهور البصر نعم فهو خطا شنيع فمن
كان بحاجه الى نظارات فيجب عليه ارتدائها
بغض النظر الضوء الازرق المنبعث من
الشاشات لا يضر العين فلا يوجد دليل قوي
يؤكد على ذلك حتى الان ولكن ممكن يصيبك
بالارق
وايضا مشاهدينا هناك علاقه بين التدخين
بصحه العين فالمواد الكيماويه سامه في
السجائر تدخل في مجرى الدم وتضر بالانسجه
في العين مقوله الجزر مفيد للنظر
صحيحه اكيد لكن النظام الغذائي الممتلي
بالجزر لن يمنحك رؤيه مثاليه كيف مفيد على
كل حال تدهور البصر ايضا ليس جزءا من
الشيخوخه معظم اسباب ضعف البصر تكون في
مرحله البلوغ لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات